Liberals are lashing out after losing
big at the Supreme Court Landmark
rulings on student loans affirmative
action and religious rights have radical
Democrats acting like spoiled children
who didn't get their way
this uh far-right extremist imbalanced
Supreme Court which seeks to make
history for all the wrong reasons they
are basically reinterpreting
Congressional statute to fit their
ideological preconceptions I support
expanding the Supreme Court because we
have a radical extreme super majority on
Supreme Court we need Supreme Court
ethics reform and we need term limits
you really need to be having
conversations about judicial review as a
check on the courts as well there also
must be impeachment on the table we have
a broad level of tools to deal with
misconduct overreach and abuse of power
oh
and if aoc's ramblings weren't unhinged
enough Sopranos actor Michael Imperioli
is coming under Fire after posting this
I've decided to forbid bigots and
homophobes from watching The Sopranos
the White Lotus Goodfellas or any movie
or TV show I've been in thank you
Supreme Court for allowing me to
discriminate and exclude those who I
don't agree with and am opposed to
maybe heat could benefit from some
mindful breathing and not ending
sentences and prepositions Boston
University law school students are being
offered therapy in the wake of the
Supreme Court rulings now
judge I just heard AOC use a term that
has a great deal of meeting meaning in
this country's history she said we have
judicial review yes in Marbury versus
Madison in 1803 chief justice Marshall
writing for unanimous Supreme Court said
that we have three co-equal branches of
government and judicial review means and
I quote a law that is repugnant to the
Constitution is void it is the job of
the Supreme Court that's a judicial
review here not you reviewing the
Judiciary AOC judicial review means the
Supreme Court reviews laws and executive
actions like the one taken in the
student loan case and sees that if it is
compatible with the Constitution
these people have no idea the people
that we just heard from one talked about
reinterpreting Congressional statute
they're very upset about that look the
Supreme Court has a has a job and the
job of the Supreme Court is to look at
legislation that's brought up for them
and decide whether or not it's
constitutional or not constitutional the
fact that they don't like that is their
problem if you don't like it go get
another law passed you're in Congress
AOC you should know that that's what you
do every day I think and the whole idea
of someone saying well you know this is
about the will of the people I think it
was Ayanna Presley who said that one
well no kidding the will of the people
52 percent of them was to overturn
affirmative action so you're wrong on
that one too and by the way as it
relates to affirmative action there was
literally no Congressional statute to
interpret so these people are clueless
and the idiocy stuns me
Richard I'm concerned about the assault
and institutions when people don't like
what happens with that institution at
that moment so we are castigating and
denigrating the Supreme Court is being
sent to right we should pack the court
we should have impeachments of certain
justices uh this actually was a mild
reaction compared to the assassination
attend last year on Justice Kavanaugh
while he and his wife and daughters were
sleeping in their home but what can we
do to convince people particularly
members of Congress whose job it is to
make the laws that's not good that's not
the Supreme Court's job to to turn down
the temperature if you don't like the
outcome tell them to pass a law help us
here I agree I think we should be
passing laws and I think there should be
Congress should pass more laws so the
Supreme Court doesn't have to interpret
as much as it does with that being said
I think when you look at some of the
rulings that came down this week I
almost agree with the judge I think we
should really be having a conversation
because I I look especially the
affirmative action it was hard to say
that once I almost agree with the judge
that was hard I wasn't listening
listen when you look at the affirmative
action case I think there's been a lot
of Bluster around who it benefits and
who it doesn't benefit right because I
think the Assumption out there is is
that somehow people of color are
benefiting tremendously via this law
right Howard's Harvard's rather black
population is 6.6 but there's some good
news still happening today because
there's a there was a complaint filed by
lawyers or civil rights against Harvard
University going after their legacy
program which we know 40 percent of the
students at Harvard University are there
because either their parents went there
or they're a millionaire and they're a
billionaire and they can buy a building
and I think that is a bigger problem in
the admissions problem and the
admissions a process in this country
than anything else yeah and I would go a
step further I think what you're also
going to see after the affirmative
action case is the beginning of the end
of standardized testing because I think
with the SATs and the acts it's another
buried entry for not only African
Americans and Latinos and Latinos but
also for poor people right because a lot
of folks now these days kids are taking
SAT prep classes in the eighth grade
that because they can afford to do it so
if you're poor and you can't afford to
do it you're sitting for a test that
somebody's been preparing for for six
seven eight years and that is indeed a
barrier to entry so if we're going to
talk about leveling the playing field
let's not go after six percent of the
student body at Harvard University let's
figure out how we go after the 40 and
make it actually fair so what do you say
to them
Jamil Hill let's let's pull that if we
can I mean we we see people talking
about these outrageous quotes here if we
can read that
I mean she's basically saying that the
Asian Americans are are complicit in
white supremacy they're carrying the
water yeah trying to exclude
African-American students when they are
just trying to be included based on
Merit but look
um Joey let me ask you this I'm very
concerned too that we've got these um
descents of snarkiness now you had one
you have um Justice Sotomayor I think in
Justice Gorsuch going at it and it's
compelled chief justice Roberts to say
listen there's a difference between
disagreement which we expect and
disparagement of each other and he's
asking them to calm down yeah real quick
I agree with you about giving poor kids
more opportunity earlier on and school
choice is a great way to do that to get
them prepared but but to move on from
that also let's not give Jamil Hill any
attention she just wants to make people
hate each other that's what she stands
for when it comes to the Supreme Court I
agree in this In The Same Spirit of of
Kumbaya I agree with Joe Biden and AOC
on some of this number one Joe Biden
said he does not believe in packing to
court he thinks that just make it more
divisive and make it more polarized and
I 100 percent agree with him on that
unfortunately his party doesn't with AOC
I love any notion to bring more ethics
to people of power I really do I I if
you want to add it to the Supreme Court
or add more to Congress or add more to
the executive branch or you know
especially when presidents and their
sons go out and make deals with other
people like bring in ethics and ethics
rules to people in power oh you might
have an agree we can work on some
Supreme Court ethics together and number
two we I love the idea of term limits I
love the idea of term limits I mean you
know somebody's fallen asleep sitting
there do they have their faculties about
them to be a Supreme Court Justice well
do they also you know that also applies
to the presidency if you want to apply
to Supreme Court Justice you know do you
have the faculties to be president so a
lot of these things they're throwing
over at the Supreme Court really they
don't want to apply to I don't know the
president and so what does that mean
they expect more from the Supreme Court
okay well I do too so then I look and I
say if I'm going to expect more from
them then maybe I'll give them a little
bit more respect and then looking at
these decisions if I want to be an actor
and I'm going to take issue with
something as intellectual and academic
as how the law works I'm at least going
to take the time to understand it the
actor said well now I get to be a bigot
and tell you you can't watch my movies
well the the Supreme Court decision
didn't say she gets to decide who looks
at her website she gets to decide how
she expresses any point of view in her
art which means the Supreme Court
reassured he never has to play a
conservative in a movie yes that is true
and that's Christopher montessante for
The Sopranos fans and he's just wrong
about what that case means
the court upheld its rationale that we
don't compel speech we don't compel
speech by you that offends your
religious beliefs in this case but let's
broaden this out a year ago after the
dove decision people said the court was
really bold in upending precedent Roe
versus waited 50 years this year the
court was asked to overturn six cases
and did not in any of those cases so
they basically agreed with the lower
courts on a number of these seminal
cases how do you characterize the end of
the term well look I'm a little
you the this idea that there's supposed
to be Democrats and Republicans
everywhere like where we have them uh in
Congress you know we don't need them in
the Judiciary I mean I'm not kidding
when I say there shouldn't be any
liberal judges a judge am I out of line
in saying that the judges should be
conservative the idea is that they
should be without politics and they
should interpret the Constitution like
you said so this idea that we're
supposed to have balance we're not
supposed to have balance there's no
Democrats to read the Constitution and
it's the legislators who are raising the
most
grief and they're the ones who are
supposed to make the law they have power
to do this I want to Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now